go to the mister mister trump
[Music]
[Applause]
dear sir donald trump is a taste
know how he's doing
good afternoon mister trump I believed in
North America what I can not believe is
that in this country there are people like
you are not able to see that if
the people are going to be your country is in
looking for opportunities not looking for va
to be the same destruction that they
they suffer in the places they leave
its main proposal is not to restore
the economy is not to cover all
problems that people have in their
country is racism is discrimination me
like to tell you that you are a
very rude person I habitat what
I have here in front, even if it's a piece
of cardboard this would be the whole class that
is exploiting the workers
Americans and the workers
Mexicans that I'm insulting that
insult with luxury of detail and that without
But it's the people who give it to swallow
that gives his fortune more than offended
I'm afraid that you will get there
[Music]
how many people have not worked
indirectly or directly with you from
Mexican origin of Mexican origin
[Music]
I also invite you to come
mexico that beyond its disadvantages
has people who are very good and who have
many things to offer mexico
[Music]